geschätzte grundwehrdiener des
österreichischen bundesheeres
ich wende mich heute ganz besonders an
sie weil sie im begriff sind einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag zur sicherheit unseres
landes zu leisten
mir ist klar dass es für sie völlig
überraschend gekommen ist dass sie ihren
grundwehrdienst um zwei monate
verlängern müssen dass sie jetzt nicht
ab kosten können und dass ihre pläne für
die kommenden monate damit über den
haufen geworfen werden
glauben sie mir wir haben diese
entscheidung nicht leichtfertig
getroffen
wir haben diese maßnahme ergriffen weil
wir sie jetzt dringend in dienst
benötigen weil sie gemeinsam mit unseren
kater soldaten dazu beitragen werden
dass österreich sicher bleibt und dass
das leben der österreicherinnen und
österreicher trotz des corona virus
weiter in geordneten bahnen verläuft
ich bitte sie die kommenden zwei monate
mit voller kraft noch durchzuhalten
danach werden ihre kameraden aus der
miliz übernehmen und sie können zu ihren
familien und sie ihrer liebsten
zurückkehren
wenngleich ihre arbeit unverzichtbar und
unbezahlbar ist so habe ich veranlasst
dass sie für die zeit der verlängerung
eine anerkennungsprämie von 190 euro pro
monat erhalten
sehen sie diese prämie bitte tatsächlich
als anerkennung als anerkennung und als
dank dafür dass sie für unser land
leisten
vergelt's gott und bleiben sie gesund